all right so our final speaker of today
is uh we're really the Sun from UIUC
speaking about dealing with the Straits
yeah Ben thanks the organizer for the
amazing workshops I'm glad to be here to
talk about a recent journey into this
random permutation something that is
very strange we have a very
understanding from I mean maybe the
whole math field it turns out to be
interesting for constrained optimization
this is joint work with Tom Lowell and
in you you yet Stamper
this is mostly if the reticle work but I
will show some simulation results to
across the line with been again
interesting simulation results so they
big big question I want to answer a lot
try to understand is to how to solve
large-scale constrained problems well
people are talking about Knox
customization for a long time but mostly
we're only solving unconstrained
problems
traditionally convex program is about
constraint optimization and interpret
methods have been very successful but
how can we apply that idea existing
ideas to constraint problems let me
briefly review the popular idea of
solving the serving unconstrained
problems mostly the idea one popular
idea is to solve the small subproblems
one by one and that's not only good for
time but also for memory we have a big
problem you cannot store in one single
machine you may want to get single
coordinate or single data one at a time
now this has been successfully applied
to corn descent and SGD is widely and
widely used in practice including deep
learning and the mark mentioned some
applications in lasso and SVM the
package currently packages are using
corn they set and also a 4 matrix
completion you can also apply these
ideas
okay so still when right has no sorry
Stephen Wright has a nice survey about
this he said well this is this site is
so simple that optimization people don't
care too much in the past
nowadays still we have a lot of
competitive ideas why do we care
well I would argue that it is compared
to other ideas it is very simple hit
some similar idea as using cheap
iteration but it's also orthogonal to
other ideas for example first-order
methods use gradient information for the
computation but it can be combined with
corn descent or a city kind of ideas and
Marc Marc showed some examples you can
use corn idea but using second-order
update so it is independent idea of
first-order methods I think
understanding this will help with other
orthogonal lines of research and another
example sketching you can do sketch but
then use this idea again now linear
constrained problems or general
constraint problems are pretty common in
practice traditionally is used in
combinatorial optimization well which is
the theme of this this workshop and also
in operations research problems and
statistical problems there are many
machine learning applications include
structures structures sparsity that you
can solve by you cannot solve easily by
traditional like proximal gradient
methods now can we apply the same
decomposition idea it turns out to be
quite tricky and I will show you some
well you ever see that in maybe half an
hour but to start with we cannot simply
apply current descent to solve the
problem because there is a constraint
and we need to consider a Lagrangian
multiplier and they use 8 mm to solve it
that's one way to solve it
okay that's the general framework of
80mm you have a general objective
function and have a linear constraints
and the former augmented Lagrangian
function and before with the primer
problem you optimize over excise and for
the old problems you do a duet send
update but turns out this algorithm
doesn't work in general for two-block
case he was known to converge for a long
time but three blockage in may diverge a
simple example is given in recent paper
showing that even for solving linear
systems it doesn't work okay since that
maybe that's just a bad idea that we
shouldn't pursue but interestingly we
found that if you randomly permute this
update order it works this this is a
simulation for that counter example the
sickly idea men diverge always and the
random permutation makes the converge
and the question is why and is there
anything interesting there this is the
outline of the talk we have talked about
motivation and it gives some background
on 80mm and the general why'd they come
of this idea and the discus convergence
analysis for people who have attended my
talk before I will give some new stuff
maybe in the last 20 minutes or so some
interesting new findings and then in the
end I will talk about convergence rate
analysis which is very tricky
theoretical problem and with some recent
progress on that ok this is the
traditional idea man
popularized by the survey of Stephen
Boyd ins and a few people including
Eckstein he got 5800 citations
surprisingly I didn't I the first time I
know I gave this talk is about 2000
citations well for mathematicians we
shouldn't care too much about attention
but still is quite interesting so they
care about the problem of objective
function is sum of two parts and they
have
constraints about the two blocks of
variables and you apply 8mm but just for
the two blocks okay
and when F and G are convex this is
known to converge multi-block case in my
diverge the question is how to make it a
converge it has been an active topical
research in the past a few years you
could change the algorithm or change the
algorithm plus the problem together
there are a lot of works on this but
we're asking a different question can we
have a minimal modification with step
size 1 and it's so simple that everybody
every engineer can understand and use it
we know now we know at least two things
one a diamond can diverge and
randomization can help condescend SGD
which was shown is the main one of the
main themes of large skeletonization in
the past maybe ten five ten years
studying from Strummer and nestor offers
influential paper on randomized corn
descent the first idea is just to
randomize they didn't man so instead of
cyclic order one two three one two three
we randomly pick the order say 1 3 2 3 1
2 and so on the bad news is it can
diverge and what's what's more strange
is it diverges for Gaussian data
Gaussian data is is usually the easiest
data you can imagine but it turns out it
diverts for that it converges for the
counter example given there okay the
second idea is use random permutation
the difference is in the independent
randomized version you may have X 3 X Y
X 1 so X 1 may repeat twice by the in
random permutation you won't repeat any
coordinates
and we have shown that it always
diverging the simulation a quick summary
these are three updated rules and random
permutation is the only one that works
in practice
well some people may say well predict
any imprecation er may not care well
even if it works for practical problems
then fine I don't care whether it
diverges or not for worst case example
ok it turns out the divergence is pretty
common ok although that a paper only
give an example we found you can't
divert with the probably one for very
common data okay this is simulation
results for Gaussian data you can see
that divergence ratio for cyclic 80mm is
only 3% very small percentage maybe
doesn't it doesn't matter if you change
the distribution to uniform zero one
data or the simplest the MATLAB command
you can have it may diverge with
probably one when you have a large
number of blocks so you don't even need
to construct a counter example there are
so many kind of examples there is
actually more common phenomenon if you
if your covariance of the variables are
large then this would that verts with
high probability it's not it's not
something about uniform or Gaussian is
more about the the matrix itself whether
it has a large of off diagonal entries
this is somewhat similar to cyclic or
descent we observe the same phenomenon
that it works not so well when you have
large off diagonal entries ok
so we claim that the divergence of
cyclamen is robust claim is not like
worst-case analysis of simplex method
okay when you perturb the problem
simplex method will work in polynomial
time or randomized version will work but
here is not the worst case is a case
example it happened quite often step
size tuning doesn't help really if at
least for constant step size strong
convexity does not help if you have step
size one another trick is maybe one
order fails how about you if you choose
a random order then effects it turns out
for this counter example it always fails
so any fixed order diverges so it's not
about a bad ordering is actually any
order works it doesn't work so why do we
care about this
it's mostly theoretical curiosity this
is something that we cannot understand
why no clue why is this this happened
and there's also a practical need so as
I mentioned we want to apply this
decomposition idea to solve large-scale
problems we don't have too many ideas
that works for large scale problems
still people are using say interior
point methods the way of huge problems
how how kind are you doing are kind of
dealing with that cyclic version doesn't
work so we have to use some more robust
version which is random permutation
second understanding this may help
understand other problems like random
permutation descent or random
permutation actually many people write
papers using randomization but when you
run experiments using random permutation
always better very record has a paper on
jellyfish and he discussed the benefit
of using random permutation actually
it's faster and even saves the sampling
time and I think another people do that
when we run a simulation
okay so we'll discuss the simple linear
system first show how to analyze
convergence it turns out to be pretty
complicated even for the simple case
this is the basic constraint problem
many people have issues with why do we
analyze this but most people have no
problem with analyzing quadratic
problems for unconstrained problem I
argue that for constrained problem a
linear system like this is as
fundamental as quadratic problems
they're essentially similar and and the
equivalent each other under some
transformation and it's already
difficult to analyze as we were seeing
the theorem we're going to prove is the
expected output which converges to the
solution of the problem we only prove
expected convergence it's not the true
convergence but is the strong evidence
for convergence and that the key result
is that if we denote the expected
duration matrix as the matrix M then we
will prove that spectral radius of the
matrix is less than 1 and notice that
the for each fixed order and the
spectral radius is greater than 1 but
when you permute them and takes part
asian it becomes smaller than 1 so why
do we use spectral analysis I think this
is really getting to the very high-level
question what kind of proof method do we
have for optimization
most people use potential function idea
and that's the one I've seen the most
like gradient descent or corn they send
or RCD they can all be analyzed using
the potential function which is the
objective function objective value for
our system if you're writing expected
update it turns out the spectral norm
which is large as the singular value is
2.3 while the largest eigenvalue is less
than 1 so we cannot use spectral norm to
analyze that so or put it another way
why transpose
my is not a potential function anymore
there is an interesting result from
control theory that if the spectral
radius of matrix M is less than one then
you can always find a potential function
pointer point out to me by four rate
there exists a matrix M so that this is
PSD and this is potential function but
the issue is is very difficult to
compute this P I don't know how to
compute it there is a closed form
expression but it is infinite son
which is impossible to compute another
yeah use PSD to find a matrix at P to
make this PS positive semi definite yes
Ami's we don't know yet we want to prove
is eigen values that's not one if you
know then this is easy
if we can find a simple format P then
after similar transformation you have
spectral norm problem another common
method is the contraction for a DMM by
Extang has a paper on that is a very
nice mathematical framework but the
issue is how to distinguish between
cyclic version and the random
permutation okay there is a relation
between this problem and a switch leaner
system in control I recently realized so
we're we're having linear system but the
the matrix the update matrix M will
change at each iteration so our PID mmm
this number of matrixes is n factorial
all possible permutation matrix is what
our problem is for every single matrix
it is not stable but using some rule it
will become stable this field is mostly
talking about always stable and actually
is really table options there's a paper
about wavelets this related wavelets do
or is called join spectral radius but
we're talking about more subtle problem
that every single state every single
matrix thing is not stable but you want
to find some way to make it stable it's
also related in front of product of
random matrix is dating back to 50 years
ago but that field doesn't provide too
much too many tools for me it's too hard
to apply okay
so the theorem 2 is mainly is a pure
linear algebra problem we have a matrix
like a transpose a matrix and you want
to get half of the entries they form a
matrix l and you take the inverse of L
and then take spectating now we want to
argue some properties of this Q that's
the essentially the problem and the
theorem claims that spectral radius of M
is less than 1 where m is a function of
a and Q it's been complicated and well
you can be simplified further but that's
the original form it turns out this
spectral radius of M is related to the
spectral radius of a Q a transpose which
is a symmetric matrix less than 1 is
equivalent to its spectral radius or
spectral not spectral radius but eigen
values lying in this region so what is
that matrix a Q a transpose it turns out
to be related to the update matrix of a
corn descent and which will prove 2nd
lemma that this is really the case and
4/3 should be tight because we find
examples greater than 1.33 so this is
really the tight estimate
so what's the relation between this and
random permuting corn they sent if you
look at the update matrix of random
familiar corn this end is I minus Q a a
a transpose a so we know RP city
converges using theory of like per
tickets or pol 10 that means the eigen
values between 0 and 2 but what we need
here is between 0 and 4/3 and as a
comparison cycling corn descent the
eigen values between 0 n well it's not
really between 0 & 2 is there are
complex numbers that's actually wrong
this is the eigen values I minus this
between minus 1 1 so what's the message
come out of this the spectrum of our PCD
is nicer than cyclic city that's what
random permutation does it's so nice
that it even for not only originally is
is distribute them in this circle inside
the disk now it forced it to be in nine
segments the line segment is between 0 &
4 thirds or yes so it shrinks by about
one third one third of it so it seems to
be a pre assigned space for our TRP
18-man okay because this result is
Balcon descent has nothing to do it amen
but there is some precise space to make
our p.m. works i don't know whether
that's coincidence or not the proof is
proof sketches this will do a simple
symmetrization
to to get induction formula and then
using and we write down the matrix
expressions to show that the eigenvalues
has have this relation it's a bit
complicated proof but it turns out works
and what is 4/3 4/3 turns out to be the
fixed point of this equation if you make
this equality make the role hat equals
row then
is four-thirds okay
I would I would like to discuss some new
findings recently there are other
variants of a radium man one variant is
motivated by the proof we found that you
don't need to use for randomization in
fact in the proof we use three levels
symmetrization but two level is enough
that motivates an algorithm called
Bernoulli random ization rule which is a
bit strange I don't think any
practitioners will would think of this
but if you have the proof this is very
reasonable we have two phases in the
phase one we sweep from 1 to N and we
throw a coin for each coordinate if it
is up then we update if no we keep it
and then phase two we come back and
update all remaining coordinates that
may be too abstract one example is you
have four coordinates you can do two or
three and then going back to four and
one that turn that's one valid order
none examples or not Vali order is
something like if you have four three
and four in the first FF phrase and the
second phase you should do two and one
but if you do one and two that's not a
valley example so there is some
difference between this randomization
and the four random permutation and is
easier to implement the only need a
binary randomization generator instead
of sampling from n coordinates okay if
you want to save on this random base
generator and we can show that this also
converges in expectation pretty much the
same proof but go ahead
right no they're both less than one but
it's just this is simpler randomization
rule so both work we have a proof for
that schedule of the proof okay maybe we
should discuss up line
there's another way to apply a
decomposition idea which is pretty
popular
I think monkey may give a talk related
to this the region the idea of M is 2 X
1 X 2 X 3 and lambda and when we permute
we premiere the primal update primal
coordinates but there is a primordial
version where you mix the primal update
and do update X 1 lambda X 2 lambda X 3
lambda this is different from originated
in men so I haven't thought about in the
beginning and this active version still
can steal that Virge for the counter
example so I think about there's no way
to try that but interesting it turns out
randomized version or independent
randomized version was proven to
converge for this rule ok so it seems
that we have a different algorithm that
works and and the proof is quite simple
if you have the independent
randomization however we I tried the
simulation it turns out to be much
slower than other versions and I will
show this the next page so in short
there is another way to apply the
composition idea and that will apply a
whole lot of new new algorithms and I
try to actually a lot of experiments but
this is one of them if you have Union
from 0 1 theta we know that segregating
men with diverged that's the figure of a
cyclic 80mm diverge we have a Bernoulli
version of that for this primordial
version it turns out to be diverge for
this case as well but random permutation
for this variant works so the two green
lines are the two random permitted
versions one for the original 80mm one
for the primal dual version both work
and both are the fastest well might one
may be faster than the other the red
line here is the randomized version it's
proven to converge but is very slow
maybe 10 times taller
okay oh you may say what this is for
Union from data but it turns out for
Gaussian data the gap is even larger
this is the Gaussian data it turns out
the primal-dual version a randomized 80
mm is the gap is maybe even larger I
don't know 100 times or 50 times smaller
slower all other methods even cyclic
adium and converges for Gaussian data
that's why I say Galison that is so nice
the cyclic adium works and Bernoulli
version works there are six methods here
five of them work but randomized version
doesn't work well it's not work is but
slow is much slower than all five other
versions I have no idea why although
aesthetically it might be their best I
summarized the comparison so there are
different update orders for either the
original version and the primal-dual
version okay cyclic is the worst that it
can diverge for more uniform data an
independent randomization works for one
case but very slow but diverge for the
other case but a newly randomization
works for one case but diverge for the
other case random permutation is the
only randomized through I know that
converge fast for both rules so you
since that random permutation is a
universal stabilizer or if you view this
as switch in the inner system it always
stabilizes the gap is even larger than
coordinate descent I've done experiments
for Corinne descent the gap may be two
times faster or may be three times this
can be ten or twenty times faster
compare the others there's a one open
question I recently realized do we have
any convergence analysis for the
primal-dual version of that or it turns
out to be not easy okay let me talk a
little bit about the convergence rate
though so this is more tricky than the
convergence actually
starless is most the results we have
seen is about independent randomized
rules if you want to get very tight
analysis is randomized Roy's the best
bet we have little understanding of
whatever rule besides that no matter
cyclic or random permutation or soap a
topo sweep you can imagine there's so
many rules there's some few works by Ben
and Steven right
they started random permutation but I
think in general why it is better
there's still an open question the
classical literature says I don't care
the different rules like porting has a
paper saying all of their rules are
essentially cyclic a rule essentially
cyclic is as long as you touch every
coordinate in finite time that's fine it
will converge for condition however the
convergence speed can be quite different
as we will see we see in the is that in
practice but also there are three attic
results about that so my first question
is can we understand the first the
simplest rule which is cyclic rule
that's the may be the oldest method in
applied math one of the oldest methods
Gauss siedel method is still in textbook
of any linear algebra course well and
and another reason is is related to
random permutation rule almost all
cyclic results can be applied to random
permutation so if we have a convergence
rate of cyclic you immediately get the
same rate for random permutation the
reason is when we analyze that we don't
care the cross iterations we just do one
cycle so that that's it and another
reason randomization not available
sometimes I think in practice you will
see that the one puzzle there has been a
positive for me quite a few years that
the known race can be sometimes N
squared
worse than randomized corn descent this
was initiated by back a few years ago
and we improved it a little bit but
still there's a large gap many people
claim cyclo order can be bad what must
be bad they say we know that one example
given by Strummer and it reached are
independently after we posting the paper
is you have multiple lines you wanted to
projection there's some geometric
understanding of that but it turns out
there's only one gap between these two
methods not Owen score gap another
another subtle is it only fails for one
particular order or maybe some
particular orders if you render in peak
in order and effects then it works so
and we want to answer this question and
we showed recently that there is really
a big gap up to all N squared times
between this two and this analysis is
based on the lower bound analysis an
example this example was proposed by
Steven writes in a few talks in 2015 but
I didn't know the examples and we
independently discovered an example and
analyzed that this is the simple table I
want to make everything simple so I
don't want to give you ten parameters I
don't have any explanation about it to
keep it simple
solving quadratic problem square
quadratic problem and we view the
gradient descent takes time one OK is
one unit which is what unit is actually
n squared times Kappa covets condition
number and the log 1 R epsilon it turns
out there's a nice nice gap that
randomized foreign descent has 1 over
tau right tell what is tau tau is a key
parameter in our skeletonization
although very few people talk about it
is the maximum eigenvalue over the
average eigenvalue is between 1 and n is
is related you so-called mo condition
number what their mo is professor
at Berkeley in linear algebra okay
randomized correlation and also SVR gee
I don't know whether people compare that
I I did calculation the SVG or saga
which are the accelerator versions of
SGD they have the same rate as
randomized Korn descent for the
quadratic problem they're both 1 over
tau so if you think and you believe that
SVG or SGD is faster than gradient
descent you have to admit tau is a big
factor that you cannot ignore it turns
out cycling condition has convergence
rate which is tell almost tell there is
some extra tau times extra factor of a
log square n and so on because of more
subtle issues but roughly speaking
cycling coordination is tau times slower
than gradient descent randomized it how
times faster so the gap between cyclic
and randomized is tau square
worst case n square okay that's the
message the analysis it turns out to be
quite tricky I think I'm in touch some
dark zone of linear algebra that
spectral radius does not provide lower
bound for the convergence rate because
in linear algebra people talk about
spectral radius that's the convergence
rate but that's just upper bound
whenever it is unreasonable it's
independent of a condition number
there's extra parameter so it's actually
getting better when you have an
inseparable problem
so tau will be equal to n if he is
totally non-separable like some ex
reckon I can write it here tau equals n
when FX equals some X I Square and the
matrix is all one matrix and however
equals one if FX equals some I X I
square now a equals a ten in majors in
this case
and for random matrix how could be in
the order of a root n
okay relation to other methods this
since gauss-seidel is almost the
equivalent to cosmos method and cosmos
method is special cases of parks parks
the projection onto convex sets the same
gap when Square gap exists for these
methods I want to say a few words about
pucks pucks dating back to of an omen in
maybe eighty years ago is a very popular
method in the apply math there is a nice
survey about this twenty years ago
including some optimizer like Adrian
boys there are some books published like
two years a few years ago called
alternating projection methods the whole
book is about this method the
convergence rate was given a classical
rate by smooth and a few people in about
forty years ago that's due in textbook a
few years ago now if we translate this
result to corn descent he actually will
get a rate dependent on all eigenvalues
so the original method is about angles
between different subspaces or different
sets but it can translate you I gain
values based on a very nice analysis I'm
there's a math that there's a inequality
about this relation it turns out this
right the classical rate of pucks nobody
knows how tight they are there are
papers claim there bunch of papers on
this convergence rate claim out this is
not tight but in there is a further
improvement but that's not tight as well
it turns out that rate can be infinite
times worse than our bound for their
counter example and we can improve is
always worse than our bound up to some
Bulgarian factor where's the
randomization in these methods is cash
Mars randomized in for sorry I'm talking
about cyclic Russian yeah okay yes
randomized these is pretty good
yeah motivation is to understand the
random permutation but cyclic is seems
to be related to that I want to mention
another thing why the convergence rate
is difficult it was studied by Ben a few
years ago they mentioned the conjecture
called a MGM inequality so so what is a
MJ meaning it's scalar version of this
is that you have some ixi to the power
of n you normalize that is greater than
the inner product or X I greater than
zero now if you want to generalize the
matrix case it becomes one over n some
IA i ^ n greater than but then you don't
have a product because it's non
commutative so you have sum over all
permutations then you have X Sigma 1 2 X
Sigma n then normalize that not X but a
so there are conjecture is we have
spectral norm than this house I think
this is still open if this inequality
holds then you will have a convergence
rate of RP city for quadratical problem
so that's why I think this is almost the
equivalent if you want to prove a
convergence ready almost prove this
inequality in some sense we propose
another variant of that which is related
to our result so we replace this general
AI by a projection matrix but we remove
this spectral norm we want to prove this
PSD inequality always holds so there is
some benefit to that because you don't
have spectral norm and and this is not
enough if we don't have our previous
result so if this hollows but combining
with our previous result eigen values
between 0 and the 4/3 then we can prove
a convergence rate of RP CD and the
reason is our result so recall the eigen
values of update matrix between minus 1
and 1
Danny converge ok we will remove one
side when you improve minus 1/2 minus
1/3 so we don't need to worry about that
side that will only give you a constant
rate matrix am gem inequality will would
deal with this the other side how close
is to this one side and we have some
results on that but still working
okay the summary we talk about
convergence analysis of RP 8mm this can
be a solver for constraint problems so
we want to really understand it but
another implication is why random
permutation is better and it's even much
better than independent randomized rule
for the constraint problems in in
probability theory in math there not too
much too many tools about this random
permutation and in linear algebra or
spectral theorem not too many tools
about spectral radius so this is really
a difficult problem another thing is the
convergence rate analysis the tight
analysis of a non independent rule we
have some understanding but more works
much many more works are needed there
are lots of open questions including the
convergence of PD version AM gem
inequality there's one thing I don't
mention Jacobi preconditioning maybe
pre-conditioner is widely used in linear
algebra but even for the simplest case
of Jacobi preconditioning which you have
a matrix with with na equal diagnosed
then you normalize it make it equal
diagonal that procedure does the improve
the condition number was not known to my
surprise and thats related to complexity
or sickening corn they send for non
equal tagging a case that still open
okay that's all thank you
[Applause]
so in the comparison between the
different variants of a DMM have you
come up with the symmetric outside
update version of the ad mm oh I have
not
yeah maybe I should because the one is
go to the conversion right right right
right right right right right
but yeah but but one reason I think I
have this paper is I think the foresight
deterministic of their row there might
be a gap between this and randomize rule
in the worst case one busy right right
thanks for the question
I think data access can be easier that
way you sample you you can put the data
there you don't need to move around you
just add a label to that and it goes
through one one loop and come back
another I think that's easier in terms
of theta x axis
[Applause]